so these are your high deals so these
sort of like these were i these were
things that we genuinely thought could
be funny for a live show and then
thought better of it realized they were
nothing yeah this is a shortened list we
have hundreds of these we just picked a
few so you you would try and come up
with a lot of ideas realize they were
bad and then they found the home in what
you call the list of nothing exactly so
listen up things started with a play i
wrote called sierno to bernie mac yeah
it was it was going to be like a
struggling young black comic was writing
bad jokes
so bernie mac comes yeah yeah we get it
marky market was a market that only sold
marky mark cds yeah
and then like we had written out the
commercial it was the commercials and it
was gonna they were gonna have really
low prices so it was gonna be like come
down to marquee market where our prices
are unbelievable
which is not a market
yeah
i know but if it's the worst
noah calls will smith yeah i think he's
the black tom hanks
he gets like frustrated but you're still
on his side like you get it he's uh
fingerbook.com that's an online
community of all the people i fingered
that's gross
go to the next one it's so many that
it's a community yes well it's a small
community and you can't you can't poke
people you can just finger them it's
right it's the worst
no it's a bad idea yeah it's nothing
yeah
lincoln navigator that's what lincoln
park calls their bus driver
that's not tommy lee jones that's the
feeling you get when you just need to
see tommy lee yeah uh that's right get a
tommy lee jones yeah
these are truly nothing no no
i think that says juilliard it's
actually juliard that's where mariachi
bands go yeah
that one well that one that one was
written by my father he came up with
that
and then hispanic at the disco is our
mariachi
okay oh god should we this one it sounds
like that's not that bad 911 was an
inside joke was the thing we wanted to
do during the election right well it was
we came up with in 2008 when uh like
hardball with chris matthews would be on
and he'd do a live show with a live
audience in the background and there'd
be a whole thing obama signs and mccain
signs and there'd be people off to the
fringe holding signs that said 911 was
an inside job so we wanted to stand next
to them with signs that said 9 11 was an
inside joke and then when chris matthews
finally went around asking people what
their signs were about he'd ask all the
people and then finally get to us and be
like 9 11 was an inside joke what it
what what does that mean and we'd be
like yeah
is a terrible dog food yeah uh
no no no no no that's a good one that's
when um like you want to borrow money
from a friend but you don't want him to
think you're home right yeah like if i
was like joe can i can i borrow five
dollars what um no hobo oh okay yeah
yeah
sorry about that
um let's go on the next yeah we don't
circumcision that's gross
that is not the it's not a rapper no
that's just what happens when you hire
too many myths
yes
it is yeah
fanny fanny whoopi is what i like to
think noah's grandma calls anal sex yeah
oh
no it probably would it probably was i
don't know
fanny whoopee
yeah
it's so gross yes
well mike my grandma she's in the ass
team oh god
there's only a hundred more of these
should we uh
forget about it yeah that's a fusion
restaurant i wanted to open that's like
half thai half italian
it was a gnocchi themed restaurant in
the new york new york casino in las
vegas
gnocchi
a corn coffee
they're like corn rows but go they go
the other way
i think that'll do it that's good
joe manny and no carving on the list of
nothing
you